well i think the idea is
to continue thinking outside the box in
different directions meaning
just like how the math allows us to
think of multiple dimensions
outside of our perception system uh sort
of thinking
um you know coming up with new tools of
mathematics or computation or
all those kinds of things to to to
to to take different perspectives on our
universe
well i'm all for that you know and i i
kind of have even elevated it into a
principle which is of complementarity
following boar that you need
different ways of thinking even about
the same things
in order to do justice to their reality
and answer different kinds of questions
about them
i mean we've several times alluded to
the fact that
human beings are hard to understand and
the concepts that
you use to understand human beings if
you want to
prescribe drugs for them or see what's
going to happen if
if they move very fast or get ex
or are exposed to radiation and so that
requires one kind of thinking that's
very
physical based
based on the fact that the materials
that we're made out of
on the other hand if you want to
understand how a person's going to
behave in a different kind of situation
you need entirely different concepts
from psychology
and there's nothing wrong with that you
can have very different ways of
addressing
the same material that are useful for
different purposes right
can you describe this idea which is
fascinating of complementarity a little
bit sort of uh
first of all what uh
state is the principle what is it and
second of all
what are good examples starting from
quantum mechanics used to mention
psychology
let's talk about this more so like one
in your new book one of the most
fascinating ideas actually
i think it's a wonderful yeah it's sort
of to me it's it's well it's the
culminating chapter of the book and i
think
uh since the whole book is about the big
lessons or big takeaways
from profound understanding of the
physical world that we've understood
that we've achieved including that it's
mysterious in some ways
the uh this was the the
the final overarching
uh lesson complementarity and uh
it's a
approach it's so unlike some of these
other things which are just facts about
the world
like the world is both big and small and
different such as this
and is big but we're not small i think
the things we talked about earlier
uh and the fact that the universe is
comprehensible and how
complexity could emerge from simplicity
and those things are
uh in some in the broad sense facts
about the world
uh complementarity is more an attitude
towards the world
encouraged by the facts about the world
and uh it's
the idea the concept of the approach
that
or the realization that uh
it can be appropriate and useful
and inevitable and unavoidable to use
very different descriptions of the same
object or the same system or the same
situation
to answer different kinds of questions
that
may be very different and even
uh mutually uninterpretable immediate
mutually
uh uh incomprehensible
uh but both correct somehow but both
correct and and
sources of different kinds of insight
which is so weird
yeah well but it seems to work in so
many cases it works in many cases and i
think
it's uh it's a deep fact about
the world and how we should approach it
it's
most rigorous form
where it's actually a theorem if quantum
mechanics is correct
occurs in quantum mechanics where
the primary description of the world
is in terms of wave functions but let's
not talk about the world let's just talk
about a
a particle an electron it's it's
it's the primary description of that
electron
is its wave function and the wave
function can be used to
predict where it's going to be
with different if you observe with it'll
be in different places with different
probabilities
or how fast it's moving and it'll also
be moving in different ways with
different probabilities that's what
quantum mechanics says and you can
predict
either set of probabilities if you
what's going to happen if i make
uh an observation of the position or the
velocity
uh but so the wave function gives you
ways of doing both of those
but to do it to get those predictions
you have to process the wave function in
different ways
you process it one way for position and
in a different way for
momentum and those ways are
mathematically incompatible
it's like you know it's like you have a
stone and you can sculpt it
into a venus de milo or you can sculpt
it into david but you can't do both
you can uh and uh
and that's an example of complementarity
but to answer different kinds of
questions you have to analyze the system
in different ways
that are mutually incompatible
but both valid to answer different kinds
of questions
so in that case it's a theorem but i
think
it's a much more widespread phenomena
that applies to many cases where we
can't prove it as a theorem
but uh it's a piece of wisdom if you
like and and
appears to be a very important insight
do you uh and if you ignore it you can
get very
confused and
misguided do you think this is um
a useful hack for
ideas that we don't fully understand or
is this
somehow a fundamental property of all
or many ideas that you can take
multiple perspectives and they're both
true well i think it's both
those both the answer to all questions
yes that's right
it's not either or it's both it's
paralyzing to think that
that we live in a world that's
fundamentally
like surrounded by complementary ideas
like
uh because it uh we want universe we
somehow want to attach ourselves to
absolute truths
and absolute truths certainly don't like
the idea of
complementarity yes einstein was very
uncomfortable with complementarity
and in a broad sense the famous poor
einstein debates
revolves around this question of whether
the complementarity that
is a foundational feature of quantum
mechanics as we have it
was is uh
a permanent feature of of the universe
and that's our description of nature
and so far quantum mechanics wins
and it's gone from triumph to triumph
whether complementarity is rock bottom i
guess we're you know
you can never be sure i mean but but uh
it looks awfully good and it's been very
successful and
certainly its complementarity has been
extremely
useful and fruitful in in that domain
uh including you know one of some of
einstein's
attempts to challenge it with
like the famous einstein podolsky rosen
experiment turned out to be
confirmations of
that that uh have have been
uh useful in themselves but so thinking
about these things was fruitful but
not in the way that einstein hoped the
the
uh
yeah so so as i said in in the case
of uh quantum mechanics and this
dilemma or dichotomy between processing
the wave function in different ways
it's a theorem they're mutually
incompatible and that the physical
correlate of that is the heisenberg
certainty principle that you can't have
position and momentum determined at once
you